[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux
seuls les slams dit toujours oui ça la
réinfection dessus du bureau de chaque
responsable politique en particulier de
ceux qui se prétendent des hommes d'état
[Musique]
se dirige-t-on vers 1 re confinement en
france officiellement le gouvernement
espère l'éviter mais la rumeur enfle
selon nos confrères du journal du
dimanche emmanuel macron pourrait
s'exprimer mercredi les prochaines
restrictions dépendront des effets du
couvre-feu le verdict est attendu cette
semaine
visart aussi des autorités la
propagation des nouveaux variants du
corona mieux
c'est pour faire face aux nouvelles
souches que des règles plus strictes aux
frontières sont entrées en vigueur ce
dimanche obligations désormais de
présenter un test pcr négatif pour les
voyageurs en provenance de l'union
européenne dans les ports et les
aéroports français
la belgique est elle a fait le choix
d'interdire à sa population les voyages
non essentiels
chacun y va donc de ses propres mesures
restrictives difficile de se coordonner
à l'échelle des 27 ou des vendeurs du
mal
[Musique]
en plein confinement le portugal votait
aujourd'hui premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle les bureaux de vote
ferment les premiers résultats sont
attendus dans la soirée
marcelo rebelo des souza devrait être
reconduit pour un second mandat en jeu
du scrutin l'abstention un scrutin
marqué donc par la crise sanitaire
alors que les 99 explosant pays
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france la thèse d'un
troisième confinement en france est de
plus en plus évoqué de nouvelles mesures
pourraient être annoncées dès mercredi
selon le jdd qui fait état d'une
possible prise de parole des manuels
macron elles seront fonction des effets
du couvre-feu des données hospitalières
et de la propagation des nouveaux
variants du coronavirus officiellement
le gouvernement dit espérer éviter un
recond finement mais ne l'exclût pas
pour autant voilà maintenant plusieurs
jours qu'il se dit prêt à prendre des
mesures plus strictes avant l'arrivée
d'une troisième vague
le récit de francs soit risqué beach le
journal du dimanche en a fait sa une
face à la menace du variant angles est
un troisième confinement serait imminent
selon l'hebdomadaire
retour donc aux limitations sortie de
déplacement concernant les commerces non
essentiels une fermeture partielle ou
une réduction des horaires d'ouverture
est envisagée mais les écoles
elle devrait rester ouverte comme
l'annoncent le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer
je préfère les modalités qui ont prévalu
en novembre avec les établissements
ouverts d'autant que nous constatons à
posteriori que notre stratégie a
fonctionné tous les scénarios existe
naturellement mais nous partageons cette
priorité éducative
toujours selon le jdd c'était manuel
maquereau en personne qui devrait
l'annoncer aux français ce mercredi date
du prochain conseil de défense sont
entrées en vigueur serait même
programmée avant le week-end prochain
pour une durée d'au moins trois semaines
pourtant l'elysée assure que rien n'a
changé dans le scénario arrêté en fin de
semaine l'exécutif attendre et d'abord
le conseil de défense de mercredi avant
de prendre une nouvelle décision
mercredi on aura des chiffres sur la
situation sanitaire est le bilan sur le
couvre feu généralisé à 18 heures cela
nous permettra de savoir si pour
l'instant cela suffit pour maintenir
l'épidémie sous contrôle il n'y a pas de
plan caché ni de scénario pré-écrit
avait déclaré olivier ferrand vendredi
soir sains nouveau confinement largement
réclamé par la communauté scientifique
mais d'ores et déjà redouté par les
français selon un sondage publié par les
échos
6 72% des français s'attendent à un
confinement seulement 41% le souhaitent
et les écoles ne fermerons qu'en cas de
nécessité absolue on vient d'entendre le
ministre de l'éducation dans ce contexte
sanitaire délicat plusieurs syndicats
l'éducation nationale où on lançait un
appel national à la grève mardi prochain
une grève pour l'emploi les salaires les
conditions de travail et d'étude
je vous propose d'écouter à nicolas
glières enseignants et membres des
stylos rouges tout livré syndicats
disons hormis l'unsa qui est vendu au
gouvernement appelle à la grève le 26
janvier mardi donc en particulier pour
nos salaires puisque nous sommes
toujours extrêmement mal payés nous
avons toujours perdu 40% de pouvoir
d'achat depuis 1983 gel du point
d'indicé ou qu'une prime de risque alors
que nous sommes le seul métier hors
médicale à être autant ni face au co
vide être mis en danger sans aucune
sécurité rien pour nous pas un centime
rien n'est fait donc nous nous allons
manif arts nous allons faire grève
nous n'appelons pas particulièrement à
des manifestations puisqu'elle serait
dangereuse vu la situation ça serait
absurde faut être cohérent mais en tout
cas nous appelons la grève nous espérons
qu'elle sera massive
nous verrons bien mais nous nous luttons
pour les salaires notre mot d'ordre chez
des stylos rouges ces salaires moyens
respect est ce qui inquiète aujourd'hui
ce sont les nouvelles souches du
coronavirus les territoires d'outre-mer
sont concernés par les variants
brésilien et sud africain un coup dur
pour les acteurs du tourisme est là mais
jen bienvenue en guadeloupe
la température actuelle est de 28 degrés
celsius la carte postale fait rêver mais
avec une certaine obligatoire et les
vacances prennent des airs de
confinement la durée moyenne d'un séjour
touristique en guadeloupe et de dix
jours alors de nombreux vacanciers
décide d'annuler leurs vols pour les
commerçants on est en train de tuer
l'économie de l'archipel
je suis inquiète parce que je pense
qu'on va rentrer dans le même scénario
que
l'année dernière trop tôt puisque
n'oublions pas qu aux antilles nous
sommes en haute saison
même si nous n'avions pas l'intention de
réaliser les chiffres de l'année est de
-1
il est évident que encore cette
situation qui a été prise samedi matin
pénalisera encore l'activité et c'est
une situation qui est catastrophique et
c'est pour nous le combat su je dirais
est encore un frais sur une activité qui
était déjà bien bienne handicap est déjà
très fragilisée par la pandémie l'an
dernier les opérateurs touristiques
espérait enfin pouvoir se refaire une
santé
ils craignent désormais de voir la
saison se terminer très vite alors
qu'elle a été lancé il ya à peine
quelques semaines la mesure d'isolement
de sept jours est entrée en vigueur ce
lundi
certains touristes sont passés entre les
filets à temps
nous marchions sont arrivés samedi donc
on l'a évité de peu c'est chouette
oui je comprend pas du tout pourquoi il
mettrait en place ici
on est livre beaucoup plus libres même
au niveau du port du masque et restent
sont ouverts il ya pas de couvre-feu et
les gens font très attention quand même
la situation n'est pas du tout anxieux
gêne et on dit beaucoup mieux ici que
qu'en france c'est l'incompréhension du
côté des commerçants et des touristes
mais pour certains professionnels de
santé
les autorités locales ont pris les
bonnes décisions certains mesure est
déjà en application dans les îles
anglophones de la caraïbe et leur a
permis jusqu'à maintenant de ne pas
déborder
je pense que appliquer chez nous elle ne
devrait pas être une mauvaise solution
c'est vraiment le moyen de s'assurer que
ne circule pas les personnes qui
pourraient se positiver après leur
arrivée sur le territoire et je crois
que dans un territoire où les capacités
de plus en charge sur un critique ne
sont pas illimitées mais il faut savoir
anticiper
il est de la responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics de décider devant le mesure tout
à fait adapté les territoires et
départements d'outre-mer sont parmi les
destinations qui intéressent le plus les
français cette année pour les vacances
de février la guadeloupe et la
martinique se cale à la deuxième et
troisième place des destinations les
plus recherchées sur expedia pour cette
période
reste à savoir si les touristes
accepteront de passer sept jours sous
cloche pour retrouver un peu le plaisir
des voyages la france ou des règles plus
strictes aux frontières sont entrées en
vigueur ce dimanche il est désormais
obligatoire de présenter un test pcr
négatif pour les voyageurs en provenance
de l'union européenne dans les ports les
aéroports français
le où chacun des 27 états membres y va
de ses propres mesures restrictives la
belgique interdit ainsi tout bonnement à
sa population les voyages non-essentiels
maxima ball en plus les jours passent et
plus la pression est forte face à la
menace des nouveaux variants anglais sud
africain ou encore brésilien
le gouvernement français a pris de
nouvelles mesures à propos de ses
frontières
après avoir annoncé mi janvier
l'obligation d'un test pcr de moins de
72 heures pour les voyageurs hors union
européenne la france a opté pour un
nouveau tour de vis à partir de ce
dimanche cet impératif est désormais
valable pour les voyageurs européens
restrictions similaires pour entrer au
portugal en italie en espagne ou encore
en allemagne la belgique pour sa part a
décidé de fermer partiellement ses
frontières les voyages non-essentiels
depuis et en provenance de son
territoire sont interdits à partir de
mercredi et jusqu'au 1er mars des
mesures parfois différente d'un pays à
l'autre
alors que la commission européenne tente
une nouvelle fois est de remédier à ce
manque d'harmonisation afin de maintenir
nos frontières extérieures et
intérieures ouverte
nous avons besoin de mesures ciblées qui
nous protège tous et au vu de la
situation sanitaire aggravée nous
déconseillons les voyages non essentiels
à la fois dans le pays
et bien sûr au delà des frontières ils
entendent fragile alors que la troisième
vague de kovy 19 qui s'abat sur l'europe
pourrait s'amplifier au cours des
prochaines semaines de nouvelles mesures
prises en ordre dispersé par les états
membres mettraient alors une nouvelle
fois l'épreuve l'unité des 27
aux pays-bas le couvre feu ne passe par
la mesure est entrée en vigueur hier
premier couvre-feu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale en terres diction
désormais de sortir entre 21h et 4h30 du
matin des manifestations se sont
déroulées dans la journée pour dénoncer
la mesure en marge des rassemblements
des heurts avec la police et des scènes
de pillage ont éclaté dans plusieurs
villes
eindhoven dans le sud du pays plusieurs
vies véhicules ont été incendiés et des
commerces de la gare centrale ont été
pillés la circulation des trains a été
interrompue au moins 30 personnes ont
été arrêtées en italie ch la lombardie
qui est repassée aujourd'hui en zone
orange un décret gouvernemental signé
hier permet au coeur économique du nord
de l'italie de quitter la zone rouge et
2 sortir du confinement dans lequel il a
été plongé pendant une semaine par
erreur en raison de mauvais chiffres sur
la situation épidémiologique de la
région réaction de me
mais partagés sur cette levée du
confinement écouter on achète à quai je
pense que cela donne un peu de répit aux
magasins et aux entreprises qui doivent
rester fermées en zone rouge
le changement ne résout pas notre
problème même la zone jaune ne résout
pas le problème mais au moins il y a une
petite ouverture
j'espère juste que nous pourrons nous
réveiller de ce cauchemar le plus vite
possible
j'ai réalisé ce matin le changement de
zone donc pour moi c'est positif car je
peux sortir
comme vous pouvez le voir il est huit
heures du matin et je veux promène ou
doux au mot juste parce que j'en avais
besoin pour ma santé mentale
mais quand même c'est cette incertitude
qui est toujours dans l'air donc c'est
positif mais je ne suis pas sûr à 100%
que ce soit la bonne chose à faire pour
l'arrêter malin j'aurais préféré rester
en rouge parce qu'une semaine d'orange
signifie maintenant deux semaines de
rouge plus tard jusqu'à ce que le vaccin
fasse son effet je ne pense pas que nous
puissions nous en sortir et pour traiter
le corona virus un anti inflammatoire
fait parler de lui ces derniers jours la
colchicine serait efficace pour réduire
les risques de complications liées à la
maladie
mais il pourrait aussi être très
toxiques en cas de surdosage
explications david khalifa l'espoir d'un
traitement l'espoir d'une alternative au
vaccin pour traiter le virus c'est tout
le pouvoir qu'aurait cette plante le
colchique d'automne en tout cas au
canada
la colchicine une molécule qui en est
extrait est présenté comme une solution
miracle par l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal grâce sai étude menée dans le
monde entier une équipe de cet institut
aurait prouvé son efficacité
selon les résultats de leur expérience
ce puissant anti inflammatoires et du
ray a drastiquement les risques de
complications liées
oco vie 19 expérimenté sur près de 4500
patients testés positifs au coc u19
le traitement a entraîné des réductions
des hospitalisations de 25 % du besoin
de ventilation mécanique de 50% et des
décès de 44% des résultats prometteurs
qui permettrait de soulager les hôpitaux
pour jean claude tardif responsable de
cette étude ce sont des résultats
importants avec un médicament qui est
connue sécuritaire peu coûteux et qui
offre finalement un espoir aux patients
avant de se retrouver à l'hôpital
nous sommes heureux de proposer le
premier médicament oral au monde dont
l'utilisation pourrait avoir un impact
significatif sur la santé publique et
potentiellement prévenir les
complications dues qu'ovide 19 pour des
millions de patients à médicaments peu
coûteux et qui serait donc efficace ça
vous rappelle forcément quelque chose
didier rahout et lead roxy chloroquine
problème est cette solution pour traiter
la maladie a été de nombreuses fois
remise en question même son de cloche
pour la colchicine la prudence est de
mise car ce médicament en surdosage peut
s'avérer toxiques voire mortels
disponible elle sur ordonnance il
présente un danger en cas à
d'automédication
bon vous allez voir passer beaucoup
d'articles sur la colchicine locaux
vides tout ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle c'est que la colchicine peut
vous tuer et que les seules choses
efficace à ce stade sur le masque et la
vaccination ne prenez pas de colchicine
de vous même pourtant québec on avance
cette découverte scientifique comme
majeurs le premier ministre québécois
s'est même félicité sur twitter et dans
les faits l'espoir est permis même si ce
traitement initialement utilisé pour
traiter la goutte peut s'avérer
dangereux aucun effet secondaire n'a été
répertorié dans cette étude met beaucoup
d'interrogations demeurent et il faut
surtout bien précisé qu'il ne guérit pas
du tout évident mais qu'il entrait bien
les complications
plusieurs experts pointent du doigt la
marge étroite entre son efficacité et sa
toxicité
de plus l institut de cardiologie de
montréal n'a pour l'instant publié qu'un
communiqué de presse sans détails sur
l'étude d'où des interrogations qui
persistent notamment sur le petit nombre
de patients testés
à ce jour on compte 27 études dans le
monde testant l'efficacité de la
colchicine chez des patients infectés
par le sar skov 2
en l'état actuel des connaissances
l'efficacité de la colchicine dans la
prévention le traitement des infections
aux copies 19 n'a pas été démontré son
utilisation ne peut donc pas être
recommandée au vu des données actuelles
pour le traitement du coït 19 des études
de plus grande ampleur et de meilleure
qualité méthodologique sont nécessaires
pour démontrer l'efficacité éventuelle
de la colchicine dans la prise en charge
du co vie 19
la solution miracle est donc pour
l'instant qu'à ses débuts mais en cette
période de crise toute bonne nouvelle
est bonne à prendre
voilà dix jours que le portugal est
soumis un deuxième confinement général
pour endiguer une explosion des cas de
kobe 19 mai le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle s'est
toutefois bien déroulée ce dimanche les
bureaux de vote sont en train de fermer
à 16h
le taux de participation évolue autour
de 35% en légère baisse par rapport à la
présidentielle de 2016 alors que
certains analystes redoutaient une
abstention record avoisinant les 70% à
l'actuel chef de l'état à marcelo rebelo
des sousa candidat pour un second mandat
est donné vainqueur dans les sondages en
jeu donc de ce scrutin le score que fera
le candidat d'extrême droite andré
ventura et pourrait créer la surprise en
arrivant 12e jeu vous propose les
écouter tous deux je dois dire que j'ai
affrontée cette élection sans aucune
nervosité et c'est ainsi que les choses
doivent se passer
ce sont les portugais qui choisissent
ils me connaissent et avec mon âge après
de nombreuses élections gagnées et
perdues
on est habitué à tout on est prêt à tout
et j'ai toujours préparé un discours de
victoire un discours de deuxième tour et
un discours de défaite c'est un triomphe
démocratique pouvoir voter malgré les
circonstances
cela signifie que nous aimons la
démocratie que nous persistons dans la
démocratie et que même la pandémie s'il
n'a pas pu arrêter la démocratie je
pense que l'abstention ne favorisera
aucun candidat
certainement pas les candidats dont les
projections sont peut-être plus élevé
d'un seul trait maxime
il est donc important pour tout le monde
et pour la démocratie que les portugais
vont des temps sans précédent avec la
pandémie
peut-être que voter n'a jamais été un
acte aussi important qu'aujourd'hui
notre avenir est en jeu donc larmes que
nous pouvons utiliser et de voter pour
aller voir l enjeu de cette élection
semble avoir trouvé écho en tout cas au
sein de la population qui s'est déplacé
malgré la situation sanitaire
même si c'est important de venir voter
alors qu'on est en confinement c'est
vrai que cela n'a aucun sens de sortir
de la maison et de se regrouper avec des
milliers de personnes qui vont venir
voter ensemble dans un même endroit ou
si tu veux permet de fermer quelque
chose c'est important d'être ici car
nous allons élire le président de la
république et c'est important pour le
pays de bien choisir
il faut voter indépendamment de la
pandémie c'est tout ou plutôt il faut
surtout votez spécialement en raison de
la pandémie
chaque fois que je peux le faire je
viens voter et remplir mon devoir de
citoyen cette année je suis en bonne
santé heureusement je suis les règles et
c'est tout 1 direction maintenant les
etats-unis qui viennent de dépasser la
barre des 25 millions 2,99 recensés
depuis le début de la pandémie à les
etats-unis sont le pays le plus touché
au monde plus de quatre cent dix sept
mille personnes ont succombé au virus
des chiffres publiés quelques jours
après l'entrée en fonction de joe biden
qui est fait de la lutte contre cette
maladie sa priorité
le dossier devrait être abordé avec
emmanuel macron dans la soirée les deux
présidents vont s'entretenir par
téléphone pour la première fois depuis
l'investiture du démocrate qui s'est par
ailleurs engagé à ce que 100 millions de
doses du vaccin soit injecté lors dès
son premier jour de son mandat le pays
s'accroche aussi à l'espoir de voir à
autoriser de nouveaux vaccins dans les
prochaines semaines dont celui de
johnson and johnson qui ne nécessite
qu'une seule dose
elle derrière les etats-unis vient le
brésil deuxième pays au monde le plus
endeuillé par le cos vide la gestion de
la pandémie par le président jacques
bolle sonar ou est plus que jamais des
criées des milliers de manifestants ont
ainsi défilé hier dans plusieurs villes
du pays pour réclamer son départ
ils protestent notamment contre le
retard pris par la vaccination
quentin auclair à 107 ans cette femme de
la communauté indigène a reçu une dose
de vaccin ce mercredi le brésil a
commencé à vacciner massivement sa
population dans la banlieue de sao paulo
les villageois voit l'arrivée du sérum
d'un très bon oeil nous sommes très
heureux de faire partie des premières
personnes à se faire vacciner ici dans
l'état de sao paulo et dans notre
communauté qui est une très grande
population
la vaccination a aussi débuté à manaus
capitale de l'état d'amazonas dont le
système sanitaire est à la limite de
l'effondrement selon le ministre de la
santé brésilien l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant a provoqué une flambée
épidémique dans cette ville située en
plein milieu de la forêt amazonienne
l'arrivée des vaccins apporte donc une
lueur d'espoir
notre lutte est une question de vie ou
de mort
nos efforts visent à sauver des vies
plus nous y parviendrons
plus les gens seront sauvés et nous
pourrons y parvenir si nous sommes unis
que dieu nous bénisse tous merci il y a
quelques jours ces images de manaus
avait fait le tour du monde
les hôpitaux étant saturés les
brésiliens faisait la queue pour
récupérer de l'oxygène et ainsi aider
leurs proches en insuffisance
respiratoire à cause du kof 19 mardi
le venezuela est venu à la rescousse de
cette ville coupée du reste du brésil
plusieurs cas nous vénézuéliens ont
apporté 132 1000 litres d'oxygène pour
approvisionner la ville de plus de deux
millions d'habitants recevoir cette
charge d'oxygène du venezuela pour la
ville de manaus est très important pour
équilibrer l'approvisionnement en
oxygène au réseau de santé public
d'amazonas
nous traversons une période difficile en
matière d'approvisionnement et toute
aide toute donation que nous recevons
est la bienvenue en particulier cette
grosse donation qui vient du venezuela
nous remercions le peuple vénézuélien de
l'affection qu'il porte à la ville de
manaus dans l'état d'amazonas et lui
adressons nos plus sincères
remerciements et notre gratitude pour le
soutien qu'ils nous apportent lundi le
brésil a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination au pied du christ rédempteur
de rio de janeiro un acte symbolique
dans un des pays les plus meurtries par
le cos vie 19 avec plus de deux cent
onze mille morts depuis le début de la
pandémie
le brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde derrière les etats
unis
et retour à présent sur cette journée de
mobilisation hier en russie en soutien
alexeï navalni des rassemblements qui
ont réuni des milliers de manifestants
dans plusieurs villes du pays dont la
capitale moscou manifestations pour
demander la libération de l'opposant
alexeï navalni a été incarcéré lors de
son retour en russie il ya tout juste
une semaine pour non respect des
conditions d'une peine de prison avec
sursis
des rassemblements non autorisés selon
les ong avaient des infos près de 3500
manifestants ont été arrêtés sur
l'ensemble du territoire
tout comme l'union européenne les états
unis ont condamné ce qu'ils qualifient
de répression les états unis dont
l'ambassade à moscou a publié sur son
site internet l'itinéraire des
manifestations officiellement pour
appelé ses ressortissants à ne pas s'y
rendre
le kremlin dénonce aujourd'hui une
ingérence écoutez à ce sujet la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe
dès vendredi l'ambassade des états unis
à moscou a commencé à oeuvrer activement
dans l'espace informatique et publier
des itinéraires de manifestations et
d'événements non autorisées qui ont été
planifiées mais les employés de
l'ambassade américaine à moscou sont
même allés plus loin ils ont diffusé une
intox
autour de supposées plan visant à mener
une campagne contre le kremlin
même les organisateurs n'avaient pas
annoncé ce genre de projet de quoi
s'agit-il
une directive une instruction il est
intéressant de noter qu'elle serait la
réaction des autorités américaines si
l'ambassade de russie à washington se
permettait la même chose je peux
imaginer comment l'itf des chemins
politiques américains serait ce qu on
verrait de l'hystérie de la russophobie
des accusations d'ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures
laurent voit deux diplomates russes etc
alors les collègues américains qui se
sont vraiment permis de s'ingérer dans
nos affaires intérieures via l'espace
informatique devront livrer leurs
explications au ministère russe des
affaires étrangères
un samedi de manifestations également en
tunisie
comme depuis plusieurs jours pour
marquer les 10 ans de la révolution du
jasmin aujourd'hui la précarité est
encore le quotidien de beaucoup de
familles et la crise sanitaire avec ces
restrictions n'arrange rien
faisant même basculer des foyers qui
n'étaient pas dans la pauvreté et
tunisiens demandent une véritable
justice sociale dimitri session jeu
samedi la foule et est à nouveau
déterminé dans les rues de tunis
comme il ya dix ans lors de la chute de
ben ali le ras-le-bol est globale ce
gouvernement à relâcher carrément il n'a
pas pu enfin fédération ni notre santé
ni la crise économique ni la caisse
politique aujourd'hui en ce biais donc
on est là pour ça les manifestations ont
d'abord eu lieu à tunis puis ont touché
les autres grandes villes du pays
sousse catherine et kirwa la crise
épidémique et ces restrictions ont
sinistré le secteur touristique qui
représentait 14% du pib en 2010 9 nous
sommes là contre le régime des frères
musulmans et de terrorisme pour nos amis
qui ont été arrêtés ce qui demandait la
chute du système
on ne sait pas où ils sont aujourd'hui
nous sommes contre ce gouvernement qui
est en train de nous manipuler
on revendique plusieurs choses la
liberté que le système des frères
musulmans incarnée par le parti ennahdha
tombe et vive la tunisie
la répression a choqué une partie de
l'opinion publique
cette mère de famille est couturière
dans une usine pour 150 euros par mois
elle affirme que son fils a été arrêté
dans le hall de son immeuble alors
qu'ils ne participaient pas aux troubles
allez c'est décidé pourquoi ont-ils
poussé la porte et emmener mon garçon de
cette manière de l'intérieur il aurait
eu le droit de l'emmener s'il avait été
dehors mais de l'intérieur
c'est ça un pays de justice excusez moi
mais c'est en pétant juste assez de
l'injustice je l' ai vu de mes yeux une
situation qui ne serait pas une
exception pour l'association avocats
sans frontières il ya une stratégie
qu'est mise en place qui est tiède car
l'objectif des dissuader les
manifestants et les jeunes arrêt sortir
dans les rues selon les ong de défense
des droits de l'homme
plus de mille personnes ont déjà été
interpellées par les autorités de fil au
début du mouvement
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur la q
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
et
détail sonic a recruté dans toutes les
couches de la société sans faire de tri
des mineurs des femmes des délinquants
des criminels de droit commun tout le
monde est venu à jaca en syrie il ya
encore quelques quelques années au
moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale est
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de kia et
de cet appel d'air justement où vos
recrutements là malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention